thank you peter it's a pleasure to speak
at this forum i just wanted to check
that everyone can see my slides
we can okay great so the work i'm going
to talk about today
is joint work with omar reingold and
waxel sharon from stanford
and my colleague odi weeder who is also
on this call
i'm going to be talking about
multi-calibration for importance weights
so our motivating problem is what is
known as
semi-supervised anomaly detection so
this is a problem we face often at
vmware
you have measurements from a data center
when it's running fine
right so you have a bunch of data that
you measured while the data set was
running well
now you're seeing fresh measurements
from the data center
and you'd like to know is it still
running fine or is there something going
wrong
right so you have two data sets one is a
normal
curated data set where you know things
are okay the other is the real world
and this may or may not be okay your job
is to find out if there's
something wrong right and this problem
you know if i had to
uh a pithy way to describe it is that
all normal points are alike but every
abnormal point is abnormal in its own
way
this is a situation which comes up in
network security system monitoring
health care and so on where it's fine to
assume that you have
a broad representative sample of what's
normal
it's not so okay to assume that you have
good examples labeled examples of what
abnormal behavior looks like
okay so how do we formulate this as a
pro
as a mathematical problem let's say that
there are two distributions
r and p which are meant to indicate the
real world versus our prior expectations
and we only have sample access to both
distributions you press a button you can
get a sample from whichever distribution
you like
based on this we're trying to assign
anomaly scores to every point
right okay how does this fit our model
well the normal points are just the
prior distribution you can think of
sampling a random row from the table
as generating a sample and the real
world examples are your samples from the
other real world distribution
and now we wish to assign anomaly scores
to points
so for a minute let's assume that we
knew everything we could know about
these distributions let's say we
actually had their pdfs explicitly
then how would we solve this problem
well in this case there's a pretty
natural solution which pops up which is
to use the importance weights
the importance weight of a point x is
the ratio of its probability under
r to p so having an importance weight of
100 means that this point
it has 100 times the probability in the
real world
that you initially thought it would have
so you better pay attention to this
right on the other hand if the anomaly
score is really low it means that you
are expecting something and it just
didn't show up this might also be of
interest to you
so in the setting in this very abstract
setting and you know if you actually had
access to the distribution functions
there's pretty much nothing else you can
do this seems the most natural thing it
has nice information theoretic
interpretations and so on
but now we only have sample access so
how
can we go about computing importance
rates
before i tell you that let me just spend
one slide telling you the completely
obvious
fact that you know these important
weights are really important in machine
learning statistics and beyond
right there's this whole area of domain
adaptation in supervised learning where
the problem is
the prior p here represents the training
distribution
r represents the test distribution that
you actually like to make good
predictions on
and often these can be different and
there's a long line of work here
saying that importance weights are very
useful because they might let you
rewrite the loss function to better
represent reality
important sampling and propensity scores
in statistics
again vast body of literature
statisticians have always known
and the rest of us are learning from
this election that in any survey certain
populations
are either under or over represented and
if you have good importance weights it
lets you correct for these biases in
your sampling
data divergence estimation
in information theory this is also
closely related to importance weights
like the care divergences in some sense
just the expectation of the log of the
importance rates
so there's this whole area of density
ratio estimation
which essentially is another name for
study of computing importance weights
the point here is that you have these
two distributions r and p
you don't really need to learn these
distributions themselves what you care
about
is just the ratio between them right
that's why the name
and our work also fits in this framework
but most of the work here treats this as
some kind of a function estimation
problem that the importance weights it's
some
function on the space let's try and
learn this function
right um okay so having told you that
this
is a broadly interesting problem what
could you do about this
can you compute importance weights from
samples alone
getting pointwise approximations are
pretty hopeless right you're just
getting samples from
these two distributions i tell you hey
the importance weight of
x is 20. now if these are large support
distributions most likely you will not
see x in either of your samples
so you know it's it's you're not going
to be able to even verify a statement
like this
how about set wise approximations let's
say both these
distributions are just drawing balls
from some distribute you know they're
drawing colorful balls let's see
a statement like the distribution r is
twice as likely to draw a red ball than
p
this is something you can verify if this
event is reasonably likely under both
distributions right
so one thing is you want to focus on
events that are likely enough
but you cannot hope to still get good
estimates
for every likely event there are
cryptographic limitations here for
instance if you're just seeing balls you
cannot verify a statement like
r is more likely to produce heavy balls
than p
because you have no way of measuring the
weight of these things right
so the takeaway from here is that we
need to think about even if we are
willing to settle for guarantees for
sets
we need to assume some niceness
properties of these sets for which we're
giving guarantees
okay so what is it we try to do in this
work well firstly we ask this question
of what constitutes give importance
weights and we put forward a candidate
notion for when our importance weight is
good
so our notion it's different from the
existing literature it's inspired by
classical notions like
indistinguishability in complexity
theory
and some very recent work in the machine
learning fairness literature that
michael kim just talked about
and one important thing here is that we
don't want to
restrict the distributions p and r in
any way
instead we are going to restrict the
class of statistical tests
or sets for which we are hoping to give
a guarantee
right the high level idea
of what we try to achieve is to define
importance weights i have a typo on this
slide we want to define
a rewaiting of p that gives us a new
distribution q
which even though it's not exactly equal
to r it looks just like r
to every test in this set so these
things are practically indistinguishable
this is what we're going for
right so here are the rules of the game
you have these two distributions p and r
on a certain domain
what you're allowed to do is to
partition this domain
into regions and what you're going for
here
is to partition it into regions where
you think all the points have roughly
the same
importance and that's it once you find
the partition
you are done thanks so
every point in the same partition is
going to get an equal weight
which is the importance the right
importance weight for this whole
partition right so this defines a new
distribution
it's a distribution where you first
sample a partition
according to r but within the partition
you sample according to your old prior
distribution
p right and these partitions depending
on the partitions you can get
r you can get p you can get a lot of
things in between
so what kind of partitions do we want
firstly we want partitions that only
have a few sets secondly
we want the resulting distribution to be
indistinguishable from
r to every test set in our
collection that we are interested in we
say it's multi accurate if this
distribution
the probability that you land in a test
set t
is the same as it would be under r so
this is the way of saying that no
test in this collection can distinguish
from this distribution versus
r itself this notion we call multi
accuracy
a much stronger notion so okay just for
a picture
here is a set and we are hoping that the
this the weight that it gets is the same
under q
as it would be under r we want this
property not just for a single set but
for every set in the collection that's
where the power comes from
a more more stronger guarantee is this
notion of multi-calibration
in multi-calibration what we ask for is
you take a test set
and now it gets partitioned into
different regions which have different
importance weight
an auditor comes by and asks you why did
this
portion of t get this importance weight
you can justify it by saying well if i
gave these points an important weight of
10
then if you look at all these points
together all these points in t that have
an importance weight of 10
they are 10 times as likely under r as
they are under p
so while i'm not sure point wise on
average we've done the right thing
and we're able to say this
simultaneously for every test
and for every important weight in our
partition
okay so okay just to wind up here uh
this
is an unsupervised anomaly it's an
unsupervised notion
an analog of the notion of
multi-calibration that michael kim just
talked about
and what we show here is that this gives
you some really nice
applications to things like anomaly
detection
divergence estimation and fairness you
can get surprisingly small partitions
that have nothing to do with the class
of tests you're trying to fool
and these are computable efficiently
assuming that your class of tests is
learnable
let me just end by saying that we are
vmware research and we are based in palo
alto
nice campus nobody goes there anymore
cody and i are on this meeting and we
are happy to talk to you
anytime thanks a lot